we also recognize just as it has been in
the united states for jamaica one of the
issues that has been presented as an
issue that is economic in the way of its
impact has been the pandemic
so to that end we are announcing today
also that we will assist jamaica in
covid recovery
by assisting in terms of the recovery
efforts in jamaica that have been
essential to i believe what is necessary
to strengthen not only
the the issue of public health but also
the economy
i personally believe
that u.s americans are unable to do so
because
some
people out there in our nation don't
have bounce and i believe that our
education like such as south africa and
the iraq everywhere like such as and
i believe that they should
our education over here and the us
should help the us
should help south africa and should help
the iraq and the asian countries so we
will be able to build up our future for
our children thank you very much south
carolina
thank you very much miss south carolina
thank you very much madam vice president
uh
kamala kamala kamala i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message
today is march
31st the last day in march in the year
2022 we are live streaming on rumble on
blaze tv and on youtube
tap subscribe buttons all that good
stuff we have a jam
packed
program for you
saw a lot of messages yesterday people
said dave you are a little more fired up
than usual we come to you for your calm
cool
collected
assessment of the news but yesterday the
hands were banging on the table
the cursing the emoting
well
i'm going to see if i can clean it up
today but we are going to talk about how
wokeism and our inept government
uh is not only destroying everything but
they are telling us what their next
moves are that's sort of the next
version of all of this they actually if
you are paying attention they are giving
us enough of a trail of crumbs to see
where they are leading us and you just
have to listen enough and pay just
enough attention to know and then once
you know where they're leading us maybe
you can do
a couple things to live a better life or
not be so affected by these lunatics uh
real quick guys i do want to remind you
that don't burn this country is coming
out on april 12th you can pick up a copy
at davereuben.com
book and if you order it now it will be
delivered to you on the 12th we got an
audio book i read it myself it's fun
you're gonna dig it we got a regular
book
there's the ebook where what how you
read books i don't know whatever you do
we got one for you and of course i am
going out on tour uh dave rubin.com
events you can join me and larry elder
and dennis prager and don jr and megyn
kelly and a whole bunch more and finally
i can now tell you that our guest in san
jose on may 15th will be the one and
only the quotable
british author and great thinker douglas
murray i'm very very excited about that
douglas will be joining me in san jose
on may 15th oh and one other thing uh
this is mostly for the reuben report uh
locals community member people uh we are
doing the q a that i posted this morning
will be tomorrow's show
not today today we've got a normal
narrative show uh the reason for that is
i have to get out of here after the show
today i am hosting a i'm the mc
actually of the the big prageru gala
this evening and i'm going to be on
stage with with dennis prager my friend
dennis prager and you're not going to
believe it this guy ron desantis have
you heard about this guy he's the
governor here in florida and uh i'm
gonna be uh bringing them on stage and
you know we're gonna do a little talk
and yada yada yada so uh i'm staying
staying over for the night so i can do
some things tomorrow so we are
pre-taping tomorrow's q a you can still
get questions in right now at reuben
report.locals.com okay let's do a show
uh joe biden the elderly man pretending
to be the president of the united states
i believe is intentionally destroying
the country i don't know if it's his
intentions because i don't think he's in
charge but someone around him has a
whole bunch of plans and they're awful
plans and they are pretty much wrecking
everything
culturally fiscally
borders the whole shebang we've got some
info here from the daily wire on biden's
new budget and it is quite bananas here
we go president joe biden's newly
released 5.8 trillion dollar budget for
fiscal year 2023 refers to equity or
uses synonymous terms over a hundred
times as his administration continues to
push an agenda critics say is anything
but moderate the plan comes out on
monday it seeks to advance equity in
dozens of government agencies like by
appropriating 48 million for a more
equitable national park system
similarly the budget would appropriate
2.6 billion dollars to the department of
state to advance gender equity and 1.5
billion to the environmental protection
agency to advance racial equity and
secure environmental justice
for communities biden's budget aims to
embed equity as a priority across the
federal government in a systemic fashion
to address barriers to opportunity for
americans as the daily wire reported on
tuesday the budget notably earmarks more
than 11 billion for climate spending in
other countries in total the white house
is calling for 44.9 billion to be
allocated toward tackling the climate
crisis which would be a 16.7 billion
increase from 2021 climate spending
biden's proposal also allocates 20
million to the department of
transportation to promote equity and
inclusion and derail against the effects
of structural obstacles to building
wealth there's also 400 million
earmarked for federal science and
technology programs so they can make use
of scientific and technological
innovation to advance equitable
outcomes the proposal comes amid a
40-year high inflation that americans
are particularly
concerned about so do you get it do you
get it how wokism has infected the
system
wholly
and one is once it is in a system the
system is pretty much done and this is
as i always say where you have to give
the devil is due you got to give these
guys and these bad ideas credit in that
they got in and they have wrought
destruction across the board the idea
that we would be caring about equity in
the united states is actually counter
to american values we should be caring
about equality equality of opportunity
that's it equity is that you're going to
have to take some people down equity is
not about bringing people up it really
is not that's that's how it's sold but
really what it's about is can we punish
certain people so that it can seem that
everyone will be the same a very simple
example of this that you all know is
what happened at harvard over the last
couple years where they felt in the name
of diversity and tolerance that they had
too many asian students so what did they
do they started punishing
young asian students who worked very
hard who in many cases came from first
or second generation immigrant families
and no one was given anything whether
they were chinese or japanese or korean
or whatever it might be they punished
those random 17 year old kids so they
said we could have more black students
or brown students or whatever it might
be nobody is against having black or
brown students at harvard obviously but
they've decided that equity
equity we should have we should balance
out these numbers based on immutable
characteristics and based on gender and
everything else that that is the most
important thing it is counter to
capitalism it's counter to competition
it's counter to individual rights it's
counter to our constitution our bill of
rights and all of that
stuff but these people don't care about
that because they don't even care about
basic math
here's biden's omb director
admitting that there's actually no data
to support the inflation situation that
they're basically running the numbers on
this bill with take a look uh cpi is
close to seven percent yeah seven point
nine percent and producer price index
ten percent
all right so in your budget you're you
think that within a few months it's
going to go down to 2.9 percent
well do you have data this would just
suggest it's going to go down to 2.9
percent like like that it's gone up
every yeah right every month that
president biden's been in office the
inflation has gone has increased it's
not gone down it's increasing you're
absolutely right and what i was going to
say is
to get a budget to you to start this
lovely dialogue we lock those inflation
and interest rates numbers in november
um and inflation has absolutely changed
um since that happened
oh
well that's something you mean you
locked in the numbers back in november
when inflation wasn't nearly as bad as
it is now and you're just putting out a
budget not based on anything that's
happening now
uh we are now basically at the end of
march one day away from april but you're
locking in the numbers uh back in
november got it so you just made up the
numbers is what you're trying to say
lady well you're not going to believe
this we have the internet here over at
the reuben report we have some data on
u.s inflation here you go the annual
inflation rate for the united states is
7.9
for the 12 months ending in february of
2022. i don't know why she didn't look
at those numbers which is the highest
since january 1982
after rising 7.5
previously according to u.s labor
department data published march 10th and
of course we all know about the
inflation situation we've been talking
about it here you guys know it you know
it when you go to the store and you see
the crazy prices on everything and one
thing that's extremely obvious is gas
prices so gas prices right now are
completely bananas they have settled a
little bit from where they were a few
weeks ago
but right now today's average gallon of
gas is 4.23
last month it was 361. that's a pretty
significant increase last year at this
time it was 287 the highest that it got
was just a couple weeks ago
that was on march 11 2022 where it was
4.33
now
you know we can look at this and go oh
this this is bad news how did this
happen are they are they trying to help
is anyone trying to help or i think we
can take a more obvious approach which
is that they want gas prices to be high
because they want to get us off gas and
fossil fuels and that their general
ineptitude related to all of these
things is what is causing supply chain
stuff it is what's causing inflation and
the fact that when you go to the store
it takes much longer to get products as
someone that just moved into a house
here in florida and by the way things
are significantly better in florida
because desantis is doing all sorts of
stuff to make sure the supply chain can
move as fast as possible but it's not
like florida has
everything in florida you need things
from other states as well
and that reminds me of that orange guy
that i often talk about because he just
did an interview and uh he brought up
that you know a lot of this stuff wasn't
happening under him
we would have never been talking i'll
give you an example supply chain
you go to a store they don't have bread
we're like a third world country they
don't have things you go to buy
something at tiffany you go to buy
something at a hardware store high low
they don't have product
they say even me when i order things
like for furnishings for a building or
something
they say it's going to take nine months
to get it used to be like same-day
service
um supply chain
we never even heard the term it wasn't
like
the the system was working the system's
totally broken our system is broken
okay so you can see the data and you can
hear trump and go okay is any of this
stuff actually true and i would say run
a test for yourself go on any website
right now to basically
buy anything go i've run this test
before live on the show some of you may
remember go to creighton barrel pick
three stories that you would normally
get a couch at go to creightonbarrel.com
go to cb2.com go to west nell wherever
you might buy a
couch and pick any random couch on there
and see how long it takes to get and you
will see it's months and months and
months and months and that things are
costing more money so you don't have to
just see the data right and you don't
have to just hear donald trump you can
figure it out in your own life we're
trying to put some flooring here in our
house uh because there's a couple cracks
in some tile and they're telling us it's
going to take months to get the very
basic thin wood flooring that should be
here pretty much overnight
but at least we have competent people in
charge that's the thing uh these are
good people these are wise people and if
they just had more of our money and more
of our attention and more power over us
they'd be doing more good stuff wouldn't
they no uh here is kate bettingfield
this is
jensaki light she is the white house
press secretary i guess saki was in a
depression yesterday couldn't show up to
the press conference so kate
bettingfield checked in and she was
asked about our crazy spending and her
answer is quite curious
how after printing trillions of dollars
taxpayers might want to know is there
not enough money to continue fighting
the pandemic trillions of dollars
you're out of it is all the accounting
done every single dollar so we have the
resources that we need in this current
moment what we need is this funding to
be able to plan for the future to
prepare for uh for as i say the
possibility of a new variant the
possibility of a new wave we don't want
to be caught flat-footed
what was that kate first off kate looks
like she's in 10th grade i don't know
where they're getting these people but i
mean she looks like she's 16 or
something um we need more money and more
bigger budgets so that we can prepare
for the future and the next wave of
coven ah
that's interesting a little hint perhaps
a little dropping of a crumb to tell us
that kovid may be coming back could that
be uh she continued though uh talking
about whether uh kovid's coming back and
what taxpayers are going to think of it
in the whole shebang go
for taxpayers would be skeptical i mean
trillions of dollars and obviously
billions more i think taxpayers want to
be prepared for the virus and they want
to make sure that we have the resources
that we need to keep them safe and
that's what this administration is
focused on
taxpayers want to be prepared for the
virus yes yes if only you guys had more
of our money we could be more prepared
for the virus that you failed miserably
at stopping
i don't like these people i don't like
them very much
but they're telling us right this is
what i'm talking about the crumbs
they're being dropped they're telling us
we need more of your money why do we
need more of your money well we always
need more of your money i mean
you know we're not very good with money
we don't really know anything about
inflation or budgets we forget to carry
the one et cetera et cetera if we just
had more your money we could protect you
from kovit because we've done so well at
it and even though we're having a little
lull in copied right now for the new
season of war over in eastern europe
they're obviously telling us that covet
is coming back we got more but before i
get to that i want to talk to you guys
about start mail you ever wonder how big
tech knows so much about you three word
three words free email services when you
click accept on those terms and
conditions you're giving that free email
provider the go ahead to scan and
analyze your email free email services
are data orders if you're done letting
big tech make billions by selling your
info in your email i suggest switching
to start mail start mail keeps your
email private period every email can be
encrypted even if the recipient doesn't
use encryption when you delete an email
it's gone forever and start mail uses
their own servers not amazon which means
they can't be put out of business if
you're already dropping big data
hoarders like facebook and jumping onto
less censored platforms then right now
is the perfect time to switch to start
mail switching to start mail is seamless
too you can easily transfer all your
current email data so there's no
starting from scratch start mail is
backed by the most stringent privacy
laws in the world you get unlimited
anonymous aliases so when you're giving
your email to a company but you want to
protect your identity start mail can
generate a shareable alias email so
people can't sell your info and they can
be deleted anytime i keep saying the way
forward is to build competitive
businesses that support our privacy
values which is why i value the service
start mail provides your cyber security
has never been more at risk email snoops
and scammers are taking advantage of
pandemic as fishing has skyrocketed in
the last year that's fishing ph not the
other kind keep your private information
private with start mail sign up today
and you'll get 50 off your first year go
to
startmail.comruben that's start with the
t s-t-a-r-t mail.com reuben for 50 off
your first year start mail.com reuben
and now back to me all right so uh
they're dropping some hints they're
dropping some hints kovid's coming back
they maybe need to keep us distracted
and keep us fearful and all of that
stuff because that's all they got
here's joe biden talking about why he
needs more your money too
even worse
if we need a different vaccine for the
future to combat a new variant we're not
going to have enough money to purchase
it
we cannot allow that to happen
congress
we need to secure additional supply now
now
new variant it's coming it's a common
and they need more money for it and what
he means by that is we need to take more
money from you so we can use it for our
stuff and it's very odd that he says
we're not going to have the money for it
unless you do what we want because this
is the same guy and the same
administration that believes that you
can just endlessly print money
if i had a printing machine downstairs
and could endlessly print money i would
be buying all sorts of things all day
long because there would be no reason
not to that's what this government
thinks but the more that it does that it
causes inflation to go up so the idea
that he's using some basic economic
theory like oh we're not going to have
money
is a little bizarre because you also
believe that you can print the hell out
of money uh but as this covid comeback
continues lord
uh here's biden this is the most
extraordinary i think this is the most
extraordinary video we're gonna show you
today here's biden pushing for
monoclonal treatments
the same monoclonal treatments that he
stopped florida from doing because they
were doing it for a year and then he
forced the federal government to move on
the states and stop them from doing it
the monoclonal antibodies take
monoclonal item bodies for example
they've helped save lives this isn't
partisan it's medicine
but congress hasn't provided enough
money to keep purchasing these
monoclonal by
anybody
it's not partisan it's medicine great
line okay who wrote that um
he literally did that the federal
government moved on florida to stop
florida from using monoclonal treatment
as some of you may remember right when
we got down here to florida in december
a little bit before christmas that's
when omicron was going crazy david and i
both got uh covid and we immediately
within the hour got monoclonal treatment
here in florida i then was sick for
about three days i had leg aches that's
it david actually was a little bit more
sick we're both unvaccinated that was
our own personal choice but obviously
we're fine now but the point is that the
administration which was railing against
monoclonal treatments which was
completely pushing four vaccine mandates
even as the evidence was coming out that
the vaccines were not working as
promised now it's about monoclonal
treatment and if he just had more money
from congress which means your money
then we would have more of the treatment
that he didn't want people getting a few
months ago
biden continued to talk about covet
here's here's a humdinger
we're now in a new moment in this
pandemic
does not mean that covet 19 is over it
means the covet 19 no longer controls
our lives that's what it means
cases are ticking up as we thought they
might
but now thanks to the foundation we've
laid america has the tools to protect
people all people and you know as we've
done from day one
my administration is making it easier
than ever for americans to access these
tools
it is true he did send every american
two covid tests remember that after the
state of the union you could get two
cova tests
made in china
that's the thing we have them downstairs
made in china you know because yeah you
get it you get it this idea that kovid
has controlled our lives well i get it
if you live in a blue state in a blue
city and you're surrounded by a bunch of
paranoid lunatics uh who want to wrap
themselves up in saran wrap and never go
out and all of those things then i
suppose it has control of your life i
live in a free state called florida
where kovit has had no bearing on
anything that i can see here at all
occasionally you do see some people
wearing masks and i don't begrudge
anyone that takes any precaution that
they wish to
but things are exploding down here in
the best sense of it economically
culturally
uh politically it's all happening and it
just is a matter of not letting it's not
that kovid controlled people's lives
it's that the government
controlled people's lives it's that you
you buffoon joe biden and the evil
taking out money the evil gavin newsom
of california someone's getting cash at
the end of the year to move to florida
it's that you people
controlled people's lives it has
absolutely nothing to do with covid
controlling people's lives but then joe
biden who does this all on a stage which
is very weird he got his fourth shot
yeah take a look so now i'm gonna get my
second booster
[Applause]
what is the shot of putin being left in
the dark by his military advisors
i'm reluctant to comment
can you comment on the declassified
intelligence that he doesn't trust his
military leadership since it is
declassified
no
mr president is the u.s willing to
provide security guarantees to ukraine
as part of peacetime
is is the us willing to provide security
guarantees to ukraine as part of peace
talks of russia
mr president are you going to extend
title 42
[Applause]
gap
i've always thought that
it discourages people getting the
vaccination when they watch people get a
needle in their arm so i apologize by
discouraging him didn't hurt a bit
and i was able to roll my sleeve up and
thank you all
[Music]
i feel very confident of everything
happening in this country when i listen
to that man and i watch whatever that
theater
show was that was a theater first off he
is on a stage do you know that that is a
sound stage with lights like i have in
this studio it's a studio he even says
why am i doing this in a studio
basically in front of people he doesn't
know what he's doing he's obviously not
in charge they're injecting the man
right in front of us it's like i think
that was pretty much the plot of the g.i
joe movie where they're rejecting the
president with something it's like what
the heck hell is going on here
is i mean really really like am i being
over the top here but is anyone watching
that and feeling confident about any of
this so that was his second booster shot
which is why i said it was his fourth
shot because you get the shot then you
get the booster you get the shot and
then you get the booster so they're just
injecting the president with stuff why
the woman next to him is wearing a mask
i don't know why is she wearing a mask
right she's obviously waxed and boosted
and everything else and let's not forget
only a few weeks ago he was with all the
other geriatric people at the state of
the union and they were rubbing heads
and sniffing hair and everything else
maybe fauci could explain some of this
to me because he's back baby remember he
took off for like three weeks we didn't
know where he was while we were doing
the war thing well now fauci is back and
he's thinking about locking you down
again
we need to be prepared for the
possibility
that we would have another variant that
would come along and if things change
and we do get a variant that does give
us an uptick in cases and
hospitalization we should be prepared
and flexible enough to pivot
towards going back at least temporarily
to a more rigid type of restriction such
as requiring masks indoor
no
dick
that is the extent of my analysis on
that one uh we've got more video from
fauci is it just a coincidence that
there is a huge coronavirus laboratory
in wuhan well i mean
it is not at all surprising
that there's a research lab in there the
chinese were trying to figure out
and did successfully figure out
what the original ideology was
of saw's cov1
and the very fact that we did have
a sars co v1
made it very very clear
that there would be a possibility that
we would have another
pandemic outbreak
from the animal human interface
so it makes very good sense
oh
you don't say
you mean the thing that we've all been
saying for two years the thing that rand
paul was going on and on about in that
senate hearing when you got very
indignant you mean the place where
they're researching the stuff and then
the thing leaks out and it's in the city
that the lab's named after and the the
lordy lordy these people are ridiculous
anyway what's good about all of this of
course is that people just are not
paying attention as much and i don't
think that if they came in and they
decided to lock everybody down yes there
would be a whole slew of people who
would say thank you sir may i have
another and they would gladly go into
their basements and drink all day and
watch porn all day and and whatever like
there's a certain set of people that
would love to just live on the
government dole and that's why the
government wants to break people because
then you're just cogs in the machine and
you'll never you'll never actualize as a
human being that's what that's what a
machine would want you're not an
individual you're just a piece of
something that's it right but enough
people are waking up i think a ton of
people are waking up i think tons of
people no longer believe the lies of
these people i think a ton of people
will not comply if they tried to and i
think there are places once again
florida would be ground zero for this
that simply will not play along and
you know if you live in say california
you live in a very different country
than here in florida and i will throw in
another five dollars into the leave cali
fund uh
finally we have chuck todd
chuck todd is a journalist over at cb uh
nbc news uh and uh as you can see even
he's getting very concerned about how
bad it's looking for the democrats let's
look at presidential job approval rating
all right when when uh bill clinton and
george w bush had midterms that went
their way their job approval rating was
was right around 50 or north of it all
right
when you start dipping below 45 you've
got a problem and you're going to have
midterms that are in the bad to
shellacking ratio
president biden's at 40. george w bush
was at 39 in 2006
we know how that turned out so you see
that's also in shellacking territory
then let's look at the generic ballot
what you're going to see here is a
narrow lead for the republicans 42 to 44
and you're going to say oh that's
competitive
no no no no in in national polling it's
extremely rare because the way
gerrymandering is work uh the way
democrats are packed into districts you
know they have more 85 percent districts
and the republicans do the bottom line
is generic ballot if the democrats are
losing it means they're going to get
walloped last time in 2010 republicans
had a two-point advantage that
translated to 63 seats so
in summary right now you've got three
essentially three numbers here that all
point into dangerous territory for the
democrats in the incumbent party
presidential job rating at forty percent
wrong track over seventy percent and the
republicans leading in the generic
ballot
not a good time
the last line that's the giveaway that's
the tell
right if you were playing cards with
this guy not a good time what do you
mean i thought you were an impartial
journalist oh but your guys are losing
so not a good time that's how you end
the segment you give all the numbers
let's just go on the assumption that
those numbers are roughly right or trust
trustworthy et cetera et cetera he
obviously feels those are not a good
time this is a lot of trouble because
it's his guys it's his administration
it's his machine so they they're telling
you what they are do you think if it had
been reversed and it looked like
democrats were gonna sweep and crush and
all of the stuff was gonna happen and
blue wave and everything else do you
think he would end it by like oh [ __ ]
man we're screwed
pretty sure he wouldn't
in case you didn't see what i was doing
there uh we got some comments from the
locals community peter says all my
savings go to gold silver and crypto the
euro is dropping so fast yeah look we've
got some money in we've got a little bit
of gold we've got a little bit in crypto
and i think everyone should diversify
you know i'm a big believer actually
this is a portion of the the new book
i'm a big believer in buying things like
buy real estate while you can you know
physical things are real and physical
and yes you should i'm not a financial
advisor obviously i mean i have some
money in retirement accounts and that
sort of thing but it feels like all of
that stuff feels very
uh uneasy right now doesn't it and it's
like a house is a house and you can live
in it owning a plot of land is there and
it's yours until the government comes in
with eminent domain but like get stuff i
i really just believe in physical things
that's my that's my own personal take on
this stuff and it's worked out fairly
well for me uh jumping jeff says based
on his behavior i think they are giving
him heroin
ah that's i would say it's as likely as
anything else that they're giving joe
biden heroin or you know what it
reminded me of that episode of the
simpsons when uh mr burns uh you find
out that he goes to this like scientific
lab somewhere where they inject him with
all these things and that's what's
keeping him alive because technically he
should be dead he has every disease
known to man and that they are all in
perfect harmony but if one gets out of
whack he'll die immediately and they
show
him getting ejected and his arm is so
frail and weak that the needle goes
right through it like that's pretty much
what we just saw right there
mad for cars says just put my disney
stock up for sale don't have much time
to go yeah you saw i canceled my disney
plus account yesterday i think the only
way we can move past this stuff and this
really is going to be the driver for for
me personally and this show going
forward is yeah we can talk about them
and we can make fun of them and we can
expose them and all that but with our
real energy
every single one of us
our real energy should be on building
new things and promoting good people and
finding alternative routes off their
endless descent into hell by the way the
daily wire yesterday
announced that they're putting a hundred
million dollars into kids programming uh
to counter what's going on with disney
and it's like that's building new things
when i built locals a couple years ago
it was because i saw that big tech was a
real problem so i built something new
and then when rumble came along chris
over at rumble had been building rumble
for years and we decided to merge the
companies together to build something
new so we have some avenues some ways
and off-ramps to get off all of this
luna
all right right after this guys i will
be taping
tomorrow's q a because i'm heading out
to this prageru gala with uh with dennis
prager obviously and governor ron
desantis maybe i'll see if i can take a
selfie with ron and right before
i'll i'll say instead of cheese i'll say
gay and see what happens say gay
we'll let's see if we can make it work
uh reminder the book is available for
right now for pre-order and then you'll
get it on april 12th
book daverubin.com and the tour is out
daverubin.com
events and the the big guest that we
just added yesterday at the san jose
event may 15th with the uh how would i
describe douglas he's just he's just
spectacular like just like one of the
best
clearest thinkers and and just a really
decent man he will be joining me in san
jose may 15th as i said so looking
forward to that if you want to play
along during the show uh live chat
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with the wolf of wall street
jordan belfort is up right now and uh
we've got a cold clothes for you today
um i'm not making it up people they uh
they've got plans and
you better start thinking about it
and the title of this session
are we ready for
a new
world order